der roman die moskauer schönheit hat ihn
international bekannt gemacht seine
autobiografie nannte er der gute stalin
er stammt aus einem land das viele im
westen nicht verstehen
ich freue mich sehr dass er heute hier
ist viktor jerofejew herr jerofejew was
passiert in der ukraine krieg es ist
kein bürgerkrieg sondern ein krieg
zwischen zwei zivilisationen die
zivilisation der humanistischen werte er
demokratisch und westlich gegen die
traditionellen russischen werte die er
totalitär und orthodoxie soluto
totalitär orthodox das russische
imperium versucht sich raum und respekt
zu verschaffen
ja und nicht zum ersten mal bereits die
sowjetunion bestand aus dem russischen
imperium und einigen angrenzenden
gebieten im westen
wissen sie die ukraine ist wie ein rad
für das auto fehlt dieses rad gibt es
kein auto es gibt sowjetische
darstellungen der ukraine als herz
gewissermaßen der industrie das objekt
union von damals das sind als auch
historische bezüge historische identität
mit der ukraine mit der krimi ist die
krim russisch krimi
[Musik]
die creme ist ursprünglich tatarische
und er dem türkischen kulturkreis
zuzurechnen
[Musik]
es gab immer wieder streit um die krim
und nicht wenige kriege bevor katharina
die große die halbinsel zum russischen
territorium erklärt hat von da an war
die creme russisch
liza die zaren unsere könige verbrachten
jeweils die sommermonate auf der krim
weil es dort schön warm ist
ich war diesen sommer auf der krim und
ich kann ihnen sagen das klima dort das
ist italien war dumm aber chruschtschow
schenkte die krim den ukraine aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen
das war 1954 das 300 jährige jubiläum
der vereinigung der ukraine mit russland
[Musik]
nach dem zusammenbruch der sowjetunion
fragte der ukrainische staatschef den
russischen präsidenten jelzin ob sie die
krim den russen zurückgeben sollten und
jelzin sagte nein
behaltet sie in der ukraine nun mit dem
wunsch vieler ukraine sich zum westen
hin auszurichten hat präsident putin
beschlossen dieses kleine geschenk
nahmen skript zum ex geschenk zu
erklären und deren territorium als
russisch ich bin der meinung wenn ich
ihnen zb mein buch gebe
und fünf minuten später sage das war ein
schönes geschenk aber trotz allem ist es
mein buch und ich will es behalten
dann können sie sagen viktor erstens ist
das unhöflich und nicht schön
zudem ist es mein buch das war ein
geschenk das gehört mir so etwas kann
man nicht einmal in einer beziehung
zwischen zwei personen machen und auf
die ebene des internationalen rechts ist
das was geschehen ist ein skandal
die identität also ist russland für die
russen auch die creme das scheint nicht
so klar zu sein dass russland die krim
braucht das scheint klar zu sein
uwe trommer
offen gesagt es geht nicht einmal um die
sowjetunion schon vor der revolution war
die creme wie ein südsee traum aus
blumen reben all das in diesem russland
der kälte in russland mit den langen
kalten winter die russische kultur
genau das ist es die russische kultur
war keine kultur des nordens weil wir
eine creme hatten wo wir hingehen
konnten um uns auszuruhen und die sonne
zu genießen
für die revolution hat die russische
intelligenz ja viel zeit dort unten
verbracht und gedichte über die creme
verfasst angefangen hat das mit puschkin
das heißt was die kultur anbelangt war
die creme für russland äußerst wichtig
nach der revolution sind wiederum poeten
und schriftsteller dorthin in die ferien
gereist dazu gehörte auch bulgakow leute
wie er die hier im westen sehr berühmt
sind cocktail war das russische saint
tropez
ich habe dort schon vor langer zeit zwei
häuser gekauft für meine familie und ich
kann ihnen ein beispiel nennen
das ist wie wenn man in portofino ein
haus kauft es ist fast das gleiche
[Musik]
ferien in der creme verbracht sie sind
sie sind fast zu hause in der klemme
wie ist die stimmung
wie ist die atmosphäre würden sie sagen
dass die denn es heute ein plebiszit
reden wird würde ein reguläres sollte
man hinter creme für russland stimmen
sie bei dir kommt dass elia
man kann es so sagen es hängt von der
tiefe der antwort aus sicht des
internationalen rechts dass im
vordergrund steht und übertreten wurde
kann man sagen das ist wirklich ein
skandal
aber aus sicht der leute auf die krim
muss man sagen dass die ukraine für die
krim nicht besonders gut war und die
politik in bezug auf die bevorzugung die
ukrainischen sprache war recht
ausgeprägt asse vor
die meisten menschen auf der krim sind
aber russisch sprach es gab bloss eine
kleine minderheit von vor allem aber
hatte es alte leute die nach abschluss
ihres arbeitslebens auf die krim gezogen
sind aprilia von djk florida wie florida
und ich kann ihnen sagen da gab es viele
die zu russland gehören wollten
angehörige der sowjetischen armee des
kgb leute die mit dem militär oder
polizeiapparat verbunden sind
[Musik]
hinzu kam dass die ukraine keine guten
straßenbauten das war die situation
trotzdem wenn sie auf die krim reisten
solange diese zur ukraine gehörte
konnten sie sagen hier wird immer noch
gefeiert
[Musik]
als ich neulich in unserem sun tropez
war das cocktail heißt musste ich
feststellen
jetzt ist das fest zu ende
[Musik]
sie zeigt sich das auf den promenaden
hat es keine menschenmengen mehr keine
jungen leute die tanzen und singen und
es gibt keine überfüllten cafés mehr
die leute die jetzt auf die krim kommen
stammen aus dem westen russlands es sind
ziemlich arme leute die von ihren
unternehmen von den fabriken geschickt
worden sind um sich dort zu erholen und
den eindruck zu erwecken dass die krim
voller menschen ist buch das sind aber
nicht mehr die jungen leute aus kraków
oder kiew die dorthin an die nackt
badestrände gereist sind und so das gibt
es nicht mehr
vielleicht ist das ein vorübergehender
zustand zwischen zwei regierungen
zwischen zwei staaten
weil offen gesagt russland wird die
krimi an die ukraine zurück geben
niemals sogar wenn navalny oder rogowski
oder wie auch immer präsident von
russland würde bliebe die krim
russisches territorium vergleichbar mit
dem elsass in zukunft das heißt wie es
heute zwischen deutschland und
frankreich keine großen schlachten ums
elsass gibt wird es in 50 jahren keine
schlacht zwischen russland und der
ukraine geben
aber während 50 jahren wird die creme
ein gebiet des anstoßes bleiben
ein gebiet mit allen möglichen problemen
zwischen der ukraine und russland
es wird ein kriegsgebiet sein eines
kalten krieges hoffe ich wird das wollte
sie gerade fragen wenn das hat er dann
fiel auch mit dem zu tun was sie ein
leben lang
als schriftsteller beschäftigt mit
russischen identität die lesbarkeit der
russischen identität dem missverständnis
gegenüber der russischen ist euch sagen
seele identität in einem in einem weiten
sinn und ich haben vor kurzem in einem
spiegel interview gesagt dass die
deutschen russland nicht verstünden das
kind vermutlich nicht nur für die
deutschen im westen sich gegenseitig zu
verstehen ist für europa und russland
immer schwierig weil sich die werte
nicht gleich entwickelt haben puzzle ist
bei euch ist es die geschichte von
werten die immer humanitäre und
humanistischer werden
die menschen werden netter auf englisch
würde man sagen nein
die lösung cisco was ist europa europa
ist der kontinent der netten menschen
nice people finde ich was ist russland
russland ist der kontinent die menschen
die denken dass es etwas wichtigeres
gibt als das volk wichtiger als das
individuum nämlich gott oder den start
das heißt wenn ich ein echter russe bin
muss ich dem russischen staat dienen
putin dienen und gleichzeitig auch der
orthodoxen kirche und dem russischen
gott nämlich genau das gegenteil hier
ist der mensch das wichtigste und der
staat muss dienen sogar gott muss dienen
das heißt er muss die möglichkeit geben
ewig zu leben und all das
[Musik]
dort ist es umgekehrt
ich bin eine kleine maschine die dem
großen instrument die
programms trügen die seiten die beiden
kategorien die politik die macht und die
religion gott haben beide vielleicht
etwas gemeinsam von zeit zu zeit also in
der russischen geschichte
das ist es mit willkür vielleicht zu tun
hat nimmt dem nicht verständnis dieser
gesetze dieser kräfte die auf einen zu
wirken und der suche nach
gesetzmäßigkeiten wenn wir putin nicht
verstehen was seine strategie ist gibt
es möglichkeiten uns zu erklären was
seine strategie ist will putin die ganze
kleine ist er gescheitert ist da eben
nicht gescheitert wir werden alles tun
um hier hat im westen seit langem
signale gegeben
schon zu beginn seiner karriere als
präsident russlands hat ihr gesagt dass
der zusammenbruch der sowjetunion die
schlimmste katastrophe des letzten
jahrhunderts war die asiatische allem
dass ihr das gesagt hat war bereits
alarmierend und er hat dinge verkündet
die für die russische demokratie für den
russischen liberalismus dicota waren
doch der westen und sogar wir glaubten
dass die ausweitung des kapitalismus in
russland und die entwicklung die
beziehungen mit dem westen putin davon
überzeugen können dass man besser mit
europa und den usa zusammen geht als
gegen sie bei uns die russischen
intellektuellen pflegten schon immer
eine kultur des humanismus
das heißt gegen den staat sogar gegen
die kirche sich gegen all diese
bewegungen zu richten so glaubte man
wäre eine große idiotie
nun beginnt putin aber in diese richtung
zu gehen
was wir heute sehen ist der beginn des
falls nicht von russland sondern dieses
regimes weil man nicht allein gegen alle
anderen antreten kann nicht einmal
weißrussland und kasachstan akzeptieren
was auf die krim geschehen ist
sie sagten nein und sie sind russlands
engste verbündete und dann ist auch
augenfällig dass russland nicht
funktioniert vor zwei tagen war ich in
weißrussland und habe die dortige
landwirtschaft gesehen sehr gut
unterhaltene feldern
[Musik]
sie überqueren die russische grenze und
alles ist chaotisch verwildert deshalb
weil dieses system nicht funktioniert
statt die krim einzunehmen hätte man
zuerst den eigenen boden bearbeiten
müssen mit den menschen arbeiten
reformen durchführen
natürlich sind die russen keine europäer
russland ist nicht gleich europa oft ist
die russische kultur sogar europäischer
als die europäische kultur
das stimmt weil es um werte geht
polankis wenn es keine freiheit gibt
wird der wert der freiheit für mich viel
bedeutungsvoller als für jene leute die
seit ewigkeiten von all diesen
mittelalterlichen dingen befreit sind
das ist sehr wichtig aber was das volk
betrifft
ich muss ihnen offen sagen russlands
größtes problem heute ist nicht putin
sondern der mangel an politischer kultur
in unserem volk dieser mangel
man kann mit den menschen dort spielen
sie sind liebenswürdig gastfreundlich
und all das
es sind gute menschen aber die
politische kultur ist null und nichts
dass das bringt nicht in einen weiteren
kreisel wenn sie diese regime die
systeme von russland von heute das
system von heute in beziehung setze
natürlich mit dem system das vorher
statt mit dem system das noch vorher
geherrscht hat diese zyklen die sich
irgendwo abwechseln vollziehen und die
frage nach der kultur die große
russische kultur die frage an sie in
ihrer funktion als schriftsteller als
repräsentanz der russischen kultur der
im westen gelesen wird und wo es
offensichtlich einen großen hunger gibt
russland auch zu verstehen über die
tagespolitik über die binären einfachen
konformen anschauungen hinüber
dann spürt man bei ihnen in ihrer
autobiografie schon beim titel etwas die
hat bürger heißt der gute stalin wenn
man es noch nicht gelesen hat denkt man
dass das ein zynisches buch sein muss
wenn man es gelesen hat wird man sehr
verunsichert weil es tatsächlich etwas
gibt was eine meine große liebe auch an
dieses land an die kultur dieses landes
an die zerrissenheit dieses landes an
die komplexität dieses landes vermittelt
lieben sie russland natürlich passiert
tut man ist ich habe mein ganzes leben
in russland verbracht durch sie nahm sie
auch schon paris meiner geburtsstadt ist
weil ich meine kindheit in paris
verbracht haben mona franck ribéry der
sein buch ich mag paris ich liebe
frankreich und europa natürlich e mail
harmonie wii resort und trotzdem ist
russland für mich sehr wichtig als
verbindung zwischen den beiden großen
kulturkreisen den kulturen asiens japan
und china und den großen kulturen
europas für einen schriftsteller ist es
gut die kulturen miteinander zu
vermischen was in diesem buch ebenfalls
vorkommt
sie müssen es sich so vorstellen
ich wohne in paris und gleichzeitig
liebe ich es in der arktis eiskristalle
zusammen mit meinem beruf ist es das
gleiche ich suche nach elementen der
menschlichen natur in russland wo alles
offenlegt
es geht nicht darum in russland bloß
russland zu finden
ich will die menschen ergründen human
beings wie es auf englisch heißt wie
funktioniert unsere seele
unser gehirn die beziehungen zwischen
den menschen
denn dort liegt alles frei russland ist
wie ein operationsteam auf dem man sehen
kann wie das herz schlägt der regierung
und bewirken körper dieses dieses ewige
herz weil ich habe den eindruck gehabt
das buch könnte auch der ewige stalin
heißen und dafür müssen wir vielleicht
ein bisschen ausholen also sie zählen
ihre geschichte ist jetzt seien die
geschichte ihrer eltern der vater war
französisch übersetzer für stalin sie
gehörten zur sogenannten goldenen
moskauer jugend mit allen privilegien
die dieses system gekannt hat sie kamen
mit acht oder von knapp mit 8 nach paris
weil ihr vater botschaftsrat für kultur
wurde in paris haben
es ist schon erteilt haben wirklich
pariser luft geschnuppert in den 50er
jahren als als in paris auch vieles
nachkriegs kulturell sich aufzubrechen
begann sie haben dann später sich der
literatur verschrieben und haben einen
hype wie soll ich sagen einen vatermord
das wird auch oft thematisiert begangen
sie haben nämlich einen almanach für
dissident russische schriftsteller mit
einer gruppe heraus gegeben
diese aber nach hat ihrem vater die
karriere gekostet und hätte noch
schlimmer kommen können
sie haben also einerseits eine eine
sowjetische biografie eine grund
biografie und sie beschreiben aber dass
dieser stalin als bild anders wie hitler
anders wie pol pot an dass mussolini in
russland einmarschiert ist dass man aus
diesem stall inis muss in russland vor
stalin und nach stellen nichts
herauskommen wird
a-rosa resort computer sie haben recht
das alles kompliziert ist sogar paradox
die für die ökonomie heute glaubt die
hälfte der menschen in russland dass
stalin ein held war historisch gesehen
ist aline mit eur positiv das ist aber
nicht der stalin der repression und des
großen terrors sondern jener stalin dir
die deutschen besiegt hat hitler das
heißt stalin ist nicht mehr ein mann der
politik sondern ein russischer gott ein
sieger der den krieg gewonnen hat der
die industrialisierung russlands
organisiert hat die ziele gesetzt hat
und groß und mächtig geworden ist
das ist als hätte stalin mehrere
historische filter durchlaufen hat
bisher jetzt praktisch in einer idee
aufgegangen ist in die idee die
russischen größe ein wenig wenn wir also
heute jemand sagt er sei stalin ist
heißt das nicht dass ihr den russischen
kapitalisten töten will oder den
schweizer kapitalisten
er will damit sagen dass auch wir jemand
sind das ist wie mit den
minderwertigkeitskomplexen aus dem
vertrag von versailles das ist das
gleiche
deshalb gibt es gewisse parallelen
zwischen der politik von putin
jener von hitler was schrecklich ist
aber es ist so mit dem anschluss und
aldi das große russland ist in den augen
vieler russen zu einer armen provinz
europas geworden
das macht sie traurig oder wütend ich
sehe es umgekehrt
für mich war das ende der sowjetunion
der große moment für neue ideen realität
die köpfe aus wechseln heißt dass man
wege für die demokratie in russland
finden muss wo immer das möglich ist so
gibeau suez braucht konzepte um
totalitäre vorstellungen durch liberale
prinzipien zu ersetzen
keiner der reformer hat das verstanden
auch geld sie nicht revanche als
quittung erhielten wir das jetzige
system dieses regime von putin der
leider als retter erschienen ist indem
er sagte nein nein wartet schaut euch an
die wirte das land wir holen uns hier
dort und die russen haben gesagt das ist
ein typ dem man vertrauen kann und bis
86 prozent der leute denken er habe
recht stellen sie sich vor 98 prozent
glauben dass er alles richtig gemacht
hat mit ihr krim nur 2 prozent sind
dagegen
so ist es in diesem land
jerofejew und die klassiker warum unser
gast dostojewski heiraten möchte und
weshalb puschkins werke wie
schmetterlinge sind viktor jerofejew
verrät an welchen russischen literaten
niemand vorbeikommt online unter srf
punkt ch schrägstrich kultur wenn sie
das erzählen über über stalin und diese
transparenz erwähnen von stalin die
eigentlich eher metaphysisch zu
verstehen ist also eine
undurchsichtigkeit habe ich den eindruck
weil sie eine schöne metapher oder eine
idee in ihrem in ihrem buch haben dass
sie sagen dass der traum des fliegens in
der sowjetunion dieser statistische
tragung des abhebens dass das des
wettrüstens das sei eigentlich die
statistische idee und das hat ja dann
etwas sehr metaphysisches in diesem buch
habe ich geschrieben dass der
stalinismus ein magischer totalitarismus
war ähnlich wie der magische realismus
in der lateinamerikanischen literatur
es handelt sich also nicht um bloße
totalitarismus wie beispielsweise in
deutschland sondern er ist gleichzeitig
magisch man verbindet mit ihm viele
träume kommunistische träume und dass es
in zukunft kein geld mehr geben wird
keinen egoismus und all das was wiederum
mit märchen verbunden ist mit
kindergeschichten sogar heute gibt es in
den köpfen die russen viele märchen
es gibt viele märchen die russen denken
dass das ende der geschichte den
untergang von kommerz und konsum dringt
und engel sie ins paradies führen werden
es ist rossi wohl die chance das stimmt
so ist es ist passé
deshalb glauben die menschen in sibirien
ernsthaft dass sie viel bedeutender sind
was die metaphysik anbelangt als die
europäer support depot war sie näher an
gott sind sie damit sind wir nicht weit
weg vom iran
auch dort gibt es dieses zusammenspiel
zwischen politik metaphysik und religion
[Musik]
wollen wie in russland das evangelium
werden im iran die inhalte des korans
mit der politik so vermischt dass der
staat und die religion zusammen gehen
und wir sind nun sehr nahe am iran
regionalen trip re mit notierung triple
was ist noch einmal genauer das ist sehr
interessant wie inwiefern sind sicher
russland und iran so nah noch einmal
schauen sie russland ist ein land wo man
glaubt die macht sei absolut up dabei
handelt es sich nicht um die macht des
volkes sondern um gottes macht der diese
macht auf den präsidenten überträgt auf
den patriarchen die kirchenleute und so
weiter mit
das ist was die russen heute glauben
gleich wie in iran kühler
damit kann man ansprüche erheben
es gibt leute die das ausnutzen es gibt
viel zynismus
aber gleichzeitig gibt es menschen die
das wirklich glauben
ich kenne nicht wenige leute das waren
meine jugend freunde die zu
propagandisten des kremls geworden sind
und die tatsächlich glauben europa ist
gut aber was ist schon europa die
europäer haben keinen lebenssinn
die wissen nicht wofür sie leben es gibt
keine großen ideen über die nation das
leben und von sich sagen sie wir russen
wissen was wir tun
wir schlagen die brücke zwischen der
grundidee gott und uns und über die
europäer sagen sie die spinnen das ist
nicht möglich
für die russen sind das menschen die
bloß konsumieren das ist nicht sehr
interessant university
also gibt es eine eine art von
spiritueller russischer überlegenheit
gegenüber dem westen interview ihr
favorisierten ich kann ihnen sagen
aktuell glauben 85 prozent der menschen
in russland dass sie den westlern
spirituell überlegen setzen
die westler glauben die russen seien
rückständig sie würden die wirtschaft
nicht entwickeln und die russen glauben
die westler würden ihre spiritualität
nicht entwickeln
sie seien nicht spirituell und hätten
keinen großen metaphysischen gott weil
man hier im westen besser nicht über
metaphysik spricht da diese mit
konservative erziehung und so weiter
gleichgesetzt
während es für die russen etwas neues
ist wie sie wissen war die religion in
der sowjetunion verboten
und nun ist die zeit der revanche für
die religion und die russen können nicht
verstehen weshalb das im westen nicht so
ist
sie sind in einem artistischen
elternhaus aufgewachsen vater hat ihm
einen relativ großen burgen als als
kommunist um die kirchen gemacht hat sie
nicht einmal das beschreiben sie auch
aus historischen oder kulturellen
gründen besuch die kirchen sie
beschreiben ihn aber als einen heiligen
kommunisten also ist hier auch eine art
von verbindung dieser metaphysik die sie
beschreiben mit dem kommunismus zu
verstehen also dass es diese art von
heiligen kommunisten gab und in ihrem
vater als einem sehr kultivierten einem
sehr distinguiert und einem aufrechten
nicht korrumpierbar 'nen kommunisten 1 1
1 parade exemplar gefunden
ja das ist der grund weshalb stalin
meinen vater sehr schätze
mein vater ist das beispiel eines guten
kommunisten die ausländische strafen
sprach englisch französisch der sehr
effizient war vieles organisieren konnte
zum beispiel hat mein vater die reise
von yves monn tor nach moskau
organisiert
1956 während der revolution in budapest
london hatte gezögert
er konnte nicht verstehen dass man
panzer mitten ins herz europas schickte
mein vater hat zusammen mit meiner
mutter wege gefunden ihn nach russland
zu holen und so ist i found on
angekommen hat angefangen zu singen und
rohstoff war da und gleichzeitig sind
die intellektuellen gekommen
sie haben begriffen dass das eine andere
art des singens war dass man auch in
metaphern singen kann
anschließend gab es in russland viele
kleine yves montand weil die leute
begriffen haben dass die imitation die
stimme von montauk ihrem leben etwas
wichtiges brachte das nachahmen einer
stimme die westlichen kultur
wer gewonnen hat weiß man nicht trotzdem
ist es natürlich schwer sich
vorzustellen als der gute stalin als
wahre ein ein terrorstaat
in unvorstellbaren dimensionen wo ganze
völker deportiert wurden massenmorde und
so weiter und sie sitzen hier und und
erzählen uns natürlich von diesen ewigen
stalin von ihrem vater der sehr darunter
gelitten hat wie die sowjetunion zu
einem ende kann seine eigene rolle war
ein spion oder war nur ein diplomat was
was war genau also diese art von von
werten also wie kann man in einem
solchen terrorsystem diese werte eines
terrorsystems vertreten und eben als
eine art heiliger mann ein etwas
besseres glauben fliegen zu wollen
asse der grund ist industrie für juni
das ist die große frage dieses buches
genau das wollte ich erklären
und ich habe gemerkt dass man das besser
mit bildern erklären kann als mit
reflektionen sie hatten recht mit ihrer
bemerkung dass mein vater in dieser
historischen katastrophe des stalinismus
ein wirklich aufrichtiger mensch war als
ich mich auf diese schrecklichen spiele
des dissidenten teams ein ließ hat er
seinen posten als botschafter der
sowjetunion in wien verloren
[Musik]
er hat mir aber deswegen nie gesagt so
etwas gehe nicht in unserer familie in
seinem letzten interview mit arte hat er
gesagt ich viktor hätte seine welt
hinter mir gelassen und jetzt beginne
ich zu weinen
er war 90 jahre alt als ihr dies sagte
kein einziges mal hat er zu mir gesagt
was hast du gemacht du hast unsere
familie ruiniert
meine mutter hat das manchmal gesagt das
ist etwas anderes das war auf einer
anderen ebene
mein vater verstand sehr wohl dass etwas
nicht funktionierte und ich schreibe in
diesem buch dass meine mutter weinte als
stalin starb mein vater niemals und als
ich ihn fragte warum er nicht geweint
habe sagte er
es blieben mir noch zwei wochen mit
molotow seinem chef und wir hätten in
den gulag gehen müssen
alles war vorbereitet die leute des kgb
hatten bereits die lampen von molotow
sport weggenommen die vorhänge alles das
ist unglaublich zwei wochen noch und er
wäre in magadan im gulag gelandet statt
als junger vater in paris und sie haben
auch recht was gott anbelangt auch wenn
mein vater keine diplomatische beziehung
zu gott hatte die es in diesem buch
heißt war er doch ein mann voller demut
es ist unglaublich es geht um das rätsel
wer wir sind die menschen die männer und
frauen deshalb verkaufte sich dieses
buch gut im iran onanieren interessant
ist dass die iranische zensur genau
diesen satz herausgepickt hat das
einzige was in diesem buch gestrichen
wurde war der satz mein vater hatte
keine diplomatische beziehung zu gott
die moskauer schönheit hingegen ist im
iran verboten
es gibt also auch grenzen was mich so
fasziniert an ihnen jetzt in dieser
geschichte zu sehen dass ihnen nichts
fremd scheint ich glaube dass sie diese
art von ideologie die
eine art glaubenssatz war völlig
überwunden haben aber nicht in ihr in
einem prozess sondern ganz natürlich in
dieser eigenen geschichte von als
kleiner junge wie ein gott in einer
naiven vorsicht die welt aneignet eine
welt die schön ist sie voller wunder ist
die voller tausenden von geschichten ist
auch ein gewisser eine gewisse ambition
diese wunderbaren eltern dieser
wunderbare vater die karriere erzählbar
etwas zu werden ist den eltern auch zu
zeigen was sie können was in ihnen
steckt und dann diese freiheit die sie
gehabt haben in diesen willentlichen
oder nicht willentlich im fahrzeugmarkt
nämlich indem sie selber zum dissident
werden und ihrem vater die karriere
nehmen abrupt dass sie sie keine eigenen
grenzen mehr kennen und das ist dann für
mich eine frage der heimat weil sie eine
dreifache heimat haben sie haben
frankreich sie haben russlands habe nach
polen als ihre dritte heimat beschrieben
sind sie eigentlich noch ein russe
diesen konnten gfg ja sagen wir wie
turgenjew der frankreich und deutschland
liebte und mit einer spanischen sängerin
liiert war
er hat viele jahre im westen gelebt
gleichzeitig war er ein großer
russischer schriftsteller viktor gheneff
ist für mich ein großartiges beispiel
aber nicht nur zur ggf google hat die
toten seelen in rom geschrieben
dostojewski ist viel in italien gereist
er hat die schweiz geschätzt
[Musik]
ich kenne dostojewski recht gut weil ich
meine dissertation über dostojewski und
den französischen existenzialismus
geschrieben habe das heißt alles war
miteinander verbunden
ich möchte unterstreichen dass die
russische kultur sehr stark verbunden
ist mit den großen figuren der
europäischen kultur und auch der
europäischen politik
wir sind in europa integriert nicht als
land aber kulturell deshalb ist meine
biografie eine paradoxe biografie weil
ich von geburt her stalin ist bin aber
gleichzeitig so privilegiert war dass
sich die fehler des systems sehen konnte
die leute in meinem umfeld waren sehr
wichtige funktionäre der sowjetunion und
ich habe begriffen dass es nicht
funktioniert das funktionierte nicht
weil es viele lügen garten und social
der boku sie rauchten nur amerikanische
zigaretten während sie amerika
kritisierten sie tranken keinen
russischen wodka sondern nur scott und
französische weine französische paar
schweizer schokolade und so weiter und
das als sowjet russen
ich habe das mit eigenen augen gesehen
auf der anderen seite habe ich die
französische kultur gesehen wie sie
wissen habe ich die kasse bekannt
ich kannte ihn motor und aragon und ich
verstand das ist da menschen gab die
total anders waren zu sehen war sehr
verlockend später habe ich verstanden
dass das menschen sind die sehr mit der
russischen kultur verbunden sind
picasso hatte beziehungen mit einigen
russischen frauen usw
man kennt das ja gut ich kann ihnen
versichern
auf kultureller ebene war ich immer
europäer und glücklich aber klar der
ursprung
war statistisch und deshalb war stalin
gut für mich für meine familie natürlich
ist dieser buchtitel sehr ironisch als
das buch in russland zu einem bestseller
wurde begannen auch die kommunisten es
zu kaufen
und ich habe ihnen gesagt kauft es nicht
weil wir einen herzinfarkt bekommen
könnten weil es sich gegen den
stalinismus richtet ihr vater hat das
buch gelesen
ja es hat ihm sehr gefallen
auch meine mutter es war eines ihrer
lieblingsbücher aber gleichzeitig gab es
doch einige ärgernisse
meine mutter hat mir gesagt viktor du
hast dem haus unserer familie zu viele
fenster geöffnet
manchmal ist dieses buch zu offenbach
force solibro rohware mama meine mutter
liebte das buch sie hat sich aber
während eineinhalb jahren geweigert mit
mir darüber zu sprechen
zuerst hat sie es gelesen und war
beeindruckt dann hat sie gesagt du hast
zu viele fenster geöffnet und ich musste
in der russischen presse einen brief an
meine eltern veröffentlichen
das war möglicherweise eine premiere in
der globalen literaturgeschichte
unter dem titel die eltern sind nicht
die kinder erklärte ich weshalb ich
dieses buch geschrieben habe nicht auf
politischer sondern auf persönlicher
ebene
ich möchte in dieser spannung noch
einmal zwischen dem osten russland und
dem westen europa auf die demokratie zu
sprechen kommen also ist russland eine
demokratie in einer zukunft wie wir sie
nach westlichen modell uns vorstellen
wie wir sie uns erhoffen für alle völker
dieser erde ist
russland irgendwann eine demokratie
elia
darauf gibt es einige antworten man kann
verschiedene wege gehen wenn sie wissen
wollen welchen weg ich persönlich sehe
ich sage ihnen russland ist aktuell
nicht bereit für die demokratie wenn wir
morgen absolut korrekte wahlen haben
könnten ohne politische machenschaften
würde nicht einmal putin gewinnen
sondern schirinowski oder ein russischer
faschist weil die leute eher auf die
rückwärtsgewandten setzen
sie wollen lieber zurück zu den werten
der sowjetunion
das ist überhaupt nicht demokratisch und
wenn sie meine meinung hören wollen wir
brauchen noch einmal jemanden wie peter
den grossen wir müssen einen neuen peter
den grossen suchen die die europäische
revolution gebracht hat das war anfangs
des achtzehnten jahrhunderts
allerdings war dies eine revolution von
oben die revolution aus dem palast
heraus info braucht es wurde verkündet
was man fortan zu tun hatte sich die
bärte abschneiden und überhaupt das
gesicht zu rasieren
man muss das system verändern man muss
beim nachtessen die frauen zum tanz
auffordern
und man muss französisch sprechen so war
das mit demokratie hat er das gar nichts
zu tun haben so der tipp hat demokratie
aber sie sagen heute 2016 russland
braucht einen zahn um zur demokratie zu
kommen leider war
wenn sie meine meinung hören wollen weil
es nicht möglich ist das system durch
parlamentswahlen zu verändern
bei uns ist alles in den händen von ex
kgb haben
es ist unmöglich auf eine revolution der
straße zu setzen ist ebenfalls unmöglich
weil sich diese revolution langfristig
gegen die demokratie wenden würde sie
ginge er richtung faschismus und weil
wir in unserem volk diese mentalität
oder kultur der politik nicht kennen
weiß ich nicht wohin das führen würde
erkläre aber ein erleuchteter mann
ich spreche wie im europa des
achtzehnten jahrhunderts
aber es braucht einen leuchteten man
dies könnte sogar medwedew sein
der unterschied zwischen stalin und
chruschtschow bestand einzig in der
ausprägung ihrer politik trotzdem hat
rohstoff alles verändert er war durch
und durch ein stalin ist und hat alles
verändert
[Musik]
momentan ist medwedew stummen er
wiederholt bloß die idiotischen dinge
des parlaments und manchmal des
präsidenten aber theoretisch könnte er
präsident werden weil ihr die nummer
zwei ist dann würde alles anders
aber vielleicht braucht es für diese
rolle nicht medwedew als präsidenten
sondern nochmals einen peter den grossen
ich weiß nicht wer zur verfügung stehen
wird
leider und das ist nicht gerade gut für
das land begreift jetzt auch putin dass
die anderen politiker demokratischer und
europäischer sind als er
weshalb er jemanden wie kadir dorf
einsetzen könnte der noch schlimmer wäre
dort setzt natürlich jetzt ein ein
anderer weg soll noch einmal ein nämlich
da
systemkritiker der offen sagt was er
meint also sein ganzes leben lang schon
immer gesagt hat und getan hat was er
denkt und was wasser wasser was ihn
antreibt sie haben auch ein buch
geschrieben 2009 die russische
apokalypse
das ist natürlich er jetzt quasi den
defätismus also nach dem schwarzen humor
deren den wir im guten stalin sehen ist
die vision dass diese apokalypse
eingetreten ist nun hat es niemand
gemerkt und wir sind mittendrin und dann
kommt natürlich die furcht wieder von
uns im westen von europa zieht uns
russland mit in diese apokalypse auch
bei der apokalypse gibt es einen
unterschied zwischen den kulturen russen
lieben die apokalypse als das ende der
zeit wo man die wahrheit finden wird aus
europäischer sicht ist das totaler
masochismus aber aus russischer sicht
ist die apokalypse der moment in dem man
die wahrheit sehen konnte war der brite
lippok alice bota lips ich denke in 30
bis 40 jahren wird russland viel näher
an europa sein dann trompeter chisora
publigroupe jetzt aber natürlich eben
diese apokalypse erfahrung wenn man
dringend ist wenn sie sagen das ist
etwas wo man der wahrheit ins gesicht
sehen kann
ihr freund bord ist neben software im
februar erschossen wurde wie in einem
agenten krimi
vor dem kreml das sind doch momente wo
russland zu einer form von wahrheit
kommen könnte unter wahrheit ins gesicht
schaut und dass die menschen die das
nicht auszahlen mache nicht von oben
sondern quasi die zivilgesellschaft
verkörpern dass diese menschen mundtot
gemacht werden oder getötet werden in
diesem system drin in dieser
konstellation sind das heißt also dass
die angst herrscht und wie gehen sie um
mit einem solchen schicksal eines
freundes und was hat das für einen
einfluss auf ihr eigenes leben
ja das stimmt
die angst regiert immer mehr dinge die
vor fünf jahren noch möglich waren gehen
jetzt nicht mehr das regime schottet
sich immer mehr ab und wird immer
grausamer wie die russische geschichte
zeigt ist das der anfang vom ende
[Musik]
das heißt das regime ist nur noch damit
beschäftigt seine eigene haut zu retten
deshalb glaube ich dass wir noch 20 bis
25 jahre mit diesem ärgernis leben
müssen die das dann werden wir wieder
auf den europäischen weg zurückkehren
aber man muss noch warten
wenn ich so spreche ist das nicht
politisch
es geht hier um die wahrheit
wäre ich nav oder roger kowski könnte
ich sagen man muss das und das machen
aber was europa anbelangt
man hat nicht gefragt was europa in
dieser situation tun keine coupons und
die antwort darauf lautet aus meiner
sicht dass europa den zukunftsträchtigen
tendenzen in russland helfen muss das
heißt die kultur unterstützen die
erziehung unterstützen
sogar die entwicklung der russischen
wirtschaft
[Musik]
klar gibt es die sanktionen trotzdem
muss man die zukunft in russland suchen
und finden wenn man die verbindungen
abbricht wird die situation noch
schlimmer
sehen sie nach stalins tod hat sich
innerhalb von zwei wochen alles
verändert zwei wochen nicht zwei jahre
nicht drei jahre
aber die leute haben aufgeatmet die
melancholisch aber damals sprachen die
menschen noch französisch und die
erziehung war noch vor revolutionär mit
einer top jetzt ist das alles verloren
man spricht in russland nicht mehr
französisch außer meine tochter die die
französische schule besucht in der nähe
der französischen botschaft in moskau
und ich sehe dass ihr verhalten anders
ist die europäische kultur vermittelt
auch eine andere körpersprache
das ist eigenartig recht die
verbindungen nicht ab es braucht sie für
die zukunft russlands im umgang mit
russland muss man sehr intelligent
vorgehen
der westen hat viele fehler gemacht
wirkliche dummheiten
in dem er gesagt hat russland ist weit
zurückgeblieben
es muss portugal hinterher rennen um
dessen lebensstandard zu erreichen
was ist das wir ein land portugal hat
man in russland gesagt und das ganze
umgemünzt wir rennen doch nicht einem
unbekannten kleinstadt hinterher wir
sind das russische reich das sowjetische
imperium
aber ich habe sie am anfang des
gesprächs gefragt ob sie russland lieben
und jetzt zum schluss dass gleich das
ganz kurz liegt russland ziehen
ob mich russland liegt das kommt darauf
an
es gibt mehr als ein russland
ideologisch gibt es nicht viele die mich
lieben weil die faschisten mögen mich
nicht die kommunisten lieben mich nicht
die anhänger putins mögen mich nicht und
sogar die liberalen haben viele probleme
mit mir weil sie glauben dass die
demokratie im orden kommen kann und ich
habe die etwas eigenartige idee dass ein
erleuchteter man wie peter der große
russland komik aber der leser der gerne
wissen möchte wie es ist eine frau zu
sein wie im buch die moskauer schönheit
oder was ist der körper des menschen die
in meinem neuen erzählband der körper
oder die akie muten die auf deutsch
übersetzt wurden
das heißt die leute die mehr erfahren
wollen über die menschliche natur die
emotionen der menschen
da gibt es viele vor allem in moskau
aber auch in ganz russland wenn ich
reise gibt es nicht wenige leute die
kommen um mich zu sehen
bücher signieren und all das
nein das offizielle russland liebt mich
nicht die offiziellen ideologen lieben
mich nicht
einzig gegenüber den lesern wie soll ich
sagen bin ich sehr glücklich
dort kann ich noch frei sein apple wolle
unsere zeit ist um herzlichen dank für
das gespräch
eine frage aber die stelle ich trotzdem
noch und zwar online auf unserer kultur
plattform dort finden sie unseren
anderem auch die wichtigsten russischen
dissidenten vernehmen
die zuhörer 5 gesprochen hat nächste
woche ist mein kollege stephan klapproth
zu gast bei dimitri im tessin und hier
geht es gleich weiter mit der
sternstunde kunst bleiben sie dran
[Musik]